hey guys and welcome to a brand new
episode of my GE only challenge uh once
again we got a ton of support on the
last episode so thank you again guys for
all of the positive comments and all the
likes uh we had over 400 likes on the
last episode and under a day pretty well
so that's awesome keep it up guys so
here's a map of uh what we progressed so
far so all we've unlocked as of yet is
the verac palace so we've gotten to 250
total level and we still have a couple
extra zones um to progress to now before
I get started I had a couple ideas I
wanted to run by you and I would
appreciate if you left your um feedback
on them in the comment section uh so
here's my two ideas to give a little
more longevity to this series and a
little more diversity for things I can
do later on uh so first off I'm
suggesting that an unlockable Zone be
the Barac sewer uh it's very close right
below the house uh District you can see
there the teal uh is would be uh theur
uh Monsters of fight Moss Giants and um
there is actually an agility shortcut
there that would leave me to the edge
Vol cave where like the Slayer Master is
stuff like that uh of course training
agility is a bit of a problem uh so
here's my other two suggestions so at
the Grand exchange there are two arrows
uh you can see on the map uh one leads
to the dwarf city of Krim and one leads
to uh the different Spirit trees I'm
suggesting that a certain level uh yet
to be determined I could have the uh
spirit tree unlocked or not the spirit
tree uh well anyway the tree that
transports you uh so I could go to The
Gnome stronghold or the trome Village
but I would be locked into that area
that's the only place I could go to
there I could trade my agility more
combo levels with the agility levels I
could go through this um shortcut in the
um rock sewer uh could even train Slayer
possibly not even sure um and the other
place is cigm which is accessible via
Minecart uh there I could train my
Mining and um there's a bunch of shops
lot OFA content but still in kind of a
restricted way uh so what do you guys
think about those uh well I guess three
ideas definitely leave a comment down
below so thanks a lot guys and let's get
started all right so I know you're
saying the first thing you're going to
do is wood cutting really after
unlocking the palace uh yes we finally
have some oak trees to cut so we're
finally getting some afkable uh wood
cutting experience it is definitely way
quicker guys uh which is nice but there
is 23 wood cutting there we go 25 wood
cutting uh still doing the oak trees not
like we have a better alternative
eventually we'll be able to get the U
trees in the north but for now we just
got this one little cluster of oak trees
to our name okay we're just about to hit
30 wood cutting and we also did finish a
random event that gave us a ruby not
that great but theoretically we could
cut willow trees now but of course we
can't all right so we're just checking
in on our flips and we have sold two
more ancient page twos uh looks like for
a 60k profit again and we sold off our
last Zam miter uh so we're definitely up
to a 1 mil cash tack for sure probably
like 1.2 mil uh so we'll find a couple
other things to flip or at least one
other thing because uh we can probably
flip a couple better items now that we
have about a 1 mil cash de and we're
kind of looking at the dragon impling
jar right now I'm not sure if we'd
actually get a margin like this but for
some reason the price is fluctuating
extremely hard uh so it's probably not a
bad idea to try to snipe one of these
and maybe get a 304k margin on an item
like this uh especially since it trades
very frequently so we'll put an offer in
for two and that'll be that all right so
we're finally going to purchase some
Mage gear uh we got the wizard robes and
a um Amulet of Glory so what we're going
to actually do is I think put it on
defensive casting because we need some
defense levels and training on the
guards in the beginning is going to suck
because they're way higher level uh than
our we can really take we're not going
to H any damage we're going to take a
ton of damage so we're going to start
off by training up our defense using M
magic because um we'll actually hit
pretty well with magic yeah we're taking
a lot of damage but we hardge getting
levels in while our hit points are
getting up pretty quick as well and our
defense very quick as well another hit
point level there's 13 uh kind of
thought what happens when we get a
medium clue scroll from these guards
don't think we'll be able to do it but
um got three defense as well so we're
getting up there all right we got our
defense to five now uh we're still
taking a reasonable amount of damage uh
14 HP um so yeah we're doing pretty well
with magic but I know as soon as we
switch to actual mes it's going to suck
cuz we're going to hit nothing all right
so we have a couple flips coming in um
the ancient page we had to drop down a
bit and the dragon impling jars we
didn't end up actually flipping for very
much but we're going to go try and train
our mes we got full steel armor and uh
steel cmar cuz we did get our defense to
uh five to wear it didn't take too long
but yeah I don't know we're still going
to take a lot of damage but we'll see
how this works all right and I think
we're going to put an offer in for the
top hat and monacle it's kind of a weird
item uh but looks like we can go from
205k to about 250 uh so we'll go ahead
and try to buy a couple of these uh they
don't trade too quickly but still pretty
decent margin and uh yeah we'll go for
three all right with melee this is
brutal I literally just killed my first
guard and that's how much food I use I
had a full inventory so this I I think I
should probably just train on imps
honestly uh to get our combat levels up
a little bit uh because this is just
brutally slow I such low accuracy I'm
barely ever hitting uh we just hit like
we hit like once every like 15 attacks
okay there we go two in a row not bad
but yeah still pretty slow we might
consider buying some super attack or
strength potions as well cuz they're not
very expensive right now and that
probably will help out quite a bit this
guy in the chicken costume just came up
to me and asked why I was killing imps
um so yeah shout out to this guy in the
chicken costume and the Abyssal whip uh
nice chatting with you man all right
there we go there is 10 strength uh now
we can probably hit like a three I don't
know not a whole lot so we'll switch
over to attack and get that to 10 as
well uh not going to train defense uh
cuz we can just do that with magic we'll
just leave that all right so we're going
to buy the super attack in strength
potion uh cuz just our accuracy is so
low uh but turning on the imps is pretty
annoying because you have to World hop
they're not always there you got to
track them down so it's pretty slow in
that regards so we'll go back and try to
fight uh the guards with only five
attack and 10 strength all right this is
moderately better I think it's probably
just onar with fighting the imps except
I don't have to track him down uh we're
just about to hit 10 attack uh you can
see how long it can take me to hit
sometimes uh we actually got a black
simitar as well to equip which will be
kind of nice A little bit of a boost in
power and I think we'll try our strength
up from now on uh but yeah still
extremely slow killing these [__]
things Okay so we've gone back to using
a magic because uh we're just taking so
much damage and uh really not doing any
so we're going to get our defense level
up maybe the 20 and then maybe the myth
armor will make a difference but anyway
there is 28 combat all right we actually
just hit a magic level so we got 44
magic and an extra combat level and
another HP level but notably we got a
medium clue scroll now I have no clue if
it's ever in any rare circumstance even
possible I don't know if there's a clue
uh spot in the castle but anyway it's
probably going to be useless all right
there we go there is 10 defense we can
finally wear some black armor or attack
stand to zero but yeah using the magic
is definitely paying off defense
experience much quicker than training it
uh with MES right now all right so we
actually just finished a random event uh
we got the best skill book in the game
uh so I didn't know the imp1 was
actually the best and now you cannot
actually put it in herblore uh someone
suggested that but it's not actually
possible so I think we're going to put
it in thieving for now uh 15 thieving
experience not a lot but yeah maybe
agility later I'm not quite sure what do
you guys think all right so now that we
have uh 10 defense um we can actually
wear the Zer robe is that how you say it
uh which is going to be a big upgrade
from
our blue hat and blue uh top uh we
didn't even have a row bottom that
actually gave us a magic bonus so that's
going to be nice actually looks pretty
cool too I'd say all right there we go
there's 20 hit points
uh still using the defensive casting uh
I think once we get 20 uh defense will
stop but for now we're at 12 defense and
the zish robe definitely helping a lot
giving us a little bit more defensive
bonus all right there's another magic
level just from fire striking 45 uh
Magic going to let us teleport to
camalot maybe I don't know does that
unlock anything useful probably not all
right there we go that is another
Defense level we're up to 15 defense
still using the orish robes uh we've
actually switched over to using Firebolt
just for fun and it's not too expensive
all right so the com grind continues uh
we're getting HP levels still we're
getting defense levels uh but more
importantly we have gotten 300 total
level off of that HP level uh so now we
can actually go and start the farming
grind if we want unfortunately the only
way to train farming without a house is
to break the leaves which is going to
suck all right guys we're going to start
raking um I don't know about this cuz I
tried hopping worlds uh we we'll try
after to see if hopping worlds makes the
grass grow back but I don't know it's
only four something experience per rake
if we can [__] rake this thing uh wow
this is taking a long ass time come on
can we please rake this uh cuz I think I
need to get well maybe there's a farming
boost I have to look into that but we
need 15 farming uh minus or plus a boost
I guess uh but okay four experience and
four experience but it's going to take a
long time it's going to be like 600
rages or something to get to 15 farming
all right uh so we're just kind of
training here we're going to go rake the
leav whenever they grow back because
hooping worlds doesn't not reset them
unfortunately but there's 20 defense we
can now wear um mythal armor so
hopefully we don't get [__] by these
guards so much when we using melee all
right so we got a full mythal set uh
finally getting some upgrades which is
nice uh the top hats still have not
boughten or bought unfortunately that's
okay but we got the mythal set which is
awesome and I think we'll finally now go
ahead and try to train a bit of our
combat attack all right guys we got a
mystery box I'm excited oh my one body
Rune [__] off all right so we got
actually a 15 strength it's finally
starting to pick up a little bit but
these uh low attack levels are still uh
hurting a bit uh but the potions help
out so much especially this low level
they're still giving us like five or six
extra attack levels which really make a
difference and they're so cheap right
now okay so we have a top hat and
monacle flip coming in uh we sold them
for a
25k margin roughly so 75k in total you
can see that there oh I guess it's more
of a 20K margin so 60k in profit not bad
uh but oh we got wow EX exactly 1 mil
what are the odds of that that's
impressive all right so we're going to
put an offer in for the monocle now uh
we tried the monocle and Top Hat monocle
so we're try the regular monacle now uh
looks like it has an insane margin this
is very cheap I'm not sure if we're
going to actually snipe any of them for
this much I'll both give with the shot
and uh yeah we'll try to find some else
I think uh next up I want to try the
armad miter again a 30k margin on this
not sure if that's going to happen we'll
go for three why not and the next up
we're probably going to do the sodomin
dehy Set uh pretty could margin of about
40 or 50k and probably more likely to
actually complete this flip uh but they
are pretty expensive so we can only
afford one I believe so we'll try to
putting it in for roughly 440 or
something uh not one coin I wish
unfortunately but we have 440 and we'll
just do one all right we're finally
grinding our way to 15 attack now we're
finally actually a little more accurate
which is nice because this first it this
took a long time to actually grind out
these levels cuz they're so [__]
inaccurate you hit like once every 10
attacks but it's getting better all
right guys we finally at 20 strength uh
we now have the combat skills to not get
totally [__] uh we have well we have
15 attack 20 strength and uh well like
25 HP and 20 defense so these guys are
finally uh giving us a break and we
could probably actually train on these
and get reasonably okay experience or
before we're only getting 2K an hour all
right we're finally about to hit 20
attacks that'll be 20 all melee stats
it's going to unlock the mythal Scimitar
which will give us a good A bit of of a
boost in damage uh but mostly we finally
gotten that early stage out of the way
guards will finally now actually be
manageable to train on uh which is nice
and uh 20 all combats is a nice way to
kind of end the training for today all
right there is a mythal citar on top of
that we also did put in a Buy offer for
energy potions we're going to do a
decanting flip uh but well we'll update
you when that actually comes through uh
decanting cheaper potions is going to be
a nice way to get actually uh some good
profit when I only have about of 1 Mill
cash stack very nice at that amount all
right so big Focus for this episode is
of course leveling up our skills um so
we're going to start by training a bit
more Fletching and now that we've gotten
to a higher Fletching level actually you
stringing the bows has become more time
efficient and profitable uh so we're
going to actually be stringing these
Willow Long bows and getting some
Fletching experience uh it's finally
gotten to the point where stringing the
bows is much more efficient TimeWise and
um monetarily it's better so there's 45
Fletching pretty quick I Sho you not
guys I'm looking through the wiki and um
all of a sudden I think I found a way to
train agility right in the grand
exchange now uh what this involves is a
toy mous which you saw I just bought for
10,000 coins uh which is a rip by any
means but when you wind it up uh release
it and you catch it you actually get
three agility experience now yeah three
agility experience just for picking it
up so this is going to be a ridiculously
long grind for anything good all right
guys we're finally going to get one
agility level from that two agility now
we need like 41 agility to go through
the shortcut which unfortunately that's
just not doable that's like thousands
and thousands and thousands of picking
these up with probably like 50 hour
grinds I don't know about that uh so one
other level up we got is 31 wood cutting
just off the oak trees once again so now
we actually have access to the adamant
axe uh which will increase our XP per
hour a little bit uh but we're still
kind of bottlenecked by the fact that
the trees we have access to is Oak Only
uh but still not bad all right guys uh
so we actually missed a couple flips we
had in the grand exchange by our
recorder CRA out anyway we went and
bought some armal KO uh for 38k and sold
them for 41 so not a very good margin
there only about 30 or 40K we gained uh
we bought the Bandos bracers uh for 90k
in total and sold them for 120 so only a
30k profit there and greenman's alss are
actually pretty promising I bought seven
of them for 46k each and we've sold
three so far for 55 and we have some
more in here as well uh so we're left
with about 1.1 mil um so we didn't
progress our cash stack too much this
episode but a lot of the uh money ended
up going into a bit of Skilling uh
mainly buying the runes for fire strike
and fire wave or not fire wave uh the
one with chaos runes anyway uh we spent
a little bit of money on armor sets we
bought am of Glory we bought um desition
robes uh so just kind of added up but as
far as our skills we're ending with 20
tax strengthen defense which is nice 27
uh hit points we managed to get two
agility uh by using the clock a wind up
Mouse which is complete AIDS definitely
don't want to do too much of that but I
will if I have to um magic we got up I
think three or four levels uh Fletching
we're actually getting pretty close to
50 uh which is nice still going pretty
flying by pretty quick and uh wood
cutting we got up to 33 no farming
levels as of yet because it is so damn
slow and that it's just hard to stay on
top when the uh weeds come back so what
do you guys think do you think it's
worth raking the weeds it's going to be
600 rakes so at three a pop it's going
to I'm going have to pay attention at
least 200 separate times uh which is
going to take a long time I mean even if
I did 10 of those a day which is pushing
it it's still going to take almost a
month uh so I don't know I think it
might be worth just to wait till I get
construction and then use the begged
tree plants uh one person has a
suggestion that I combine salt Peters
with compost unfortunately you can't do
that unless you have 5% in one of the Za
hoses so again thanks everyone for all
the suggestions all the comments and uh
make sure to toss the video like if you
are enjoying the series and uh yeah hope
you guys enjoyed the episode and I'll
see you guys in the next one
[Music]
h